year that twenty thousand deaths from
kovid would be a good outcome
and yet the ons today putting out
figures of a hundred and fifty
thousand people that have lost their
lives and marie curie the end of life
charity saying that it estimates one in
ten nearly britain's
uh or sorry six million people have
suffered a bereavement it gives you a
sense of the enormity
of a year that has affected all of us uh
in so many different ways and i think
when the prime minister speaks
today he will try and capture a sense of
that a cabinet this morning
he said he began opening it reflecting
on what he had called a very dark and
difficult year for the country
he said to his cabinet colleagues we
mourn all those who have
been lost to this covid uh crisis we
send our deeper sympathies to their
family
friends and their loved ones uh and then
he talked too
about the uh incredible work of
scientists
to develop a vaccine within such a short
time which the nhs
is now rolling out to such great effects
so i think there will be a sense of hope
too
in this press conference that after a
very long and dark year
the end now is in sight i don't expect
any big news announcements i really
think this will be a moment where the
prime minister wants to try
and uh reflect upon the year that has
passed and paid tribute to the front
care
staff to hospital workers to shop
workers to the postmen to the bus
drivers to all the people that kept
the country running to thank the
scientists and also reflect on what has
been
a truly difficult year beth mark austin
here now just waiting uh
for five o'clock to come up and uh boris
johnson to begin this
news conference um so you think it will
be mainly a reflective
news conference in many ways i guess
though there will be questions about the
politics of all this and the
the new legislation that uh mps are
going to have to vote on i think
this thursday isn't it yeah there will
be questions
around the legislation we know that many
conservative mps
are deeply uncomfortable uh with some of
this
legislation which paves the way uh for
more
legal powers for the government to keep
us locked down for longer the prime
minister sticking
to that road map despite this third wave
now emerging
on the continent he will address
conservative mps
at the 1922 the back bench committee
later on this evening after the press
conference but the big question too is
about this
inquiry this public inquiry that the
government
have promised there was some questions
about whether the prime minister might
use this moment to announce that i don't
think he
will i think that the government's
position is now is not the time
you saw jonathan van tan the deputy
chief medical officer
last week saying that yes there should
be an inquiry to learn the lessons for
future pandemics
but he wanted to get on with rolling out
the vaccine didn't want
a distraction of course it's obvious too
that once that vaccine is rolled out uh
towards the end of the summer and into
autumn
could that be a moment to launch that
public inquiry something cirque here
stammer
has used today to demand again something
that i imagine the prime minister for
the time being will push back on
right also chris witte will be there
patrick valance
uh will be there and chris whittie was
saying earlier today he's convinced that
there will be
another surge at some stage
yeah and when i've spoken to senior
ministers about this about the unlocking
there is an expectation that there will
be
a surge when you unlock society of
course
case numbers will increase although
there is a massive vaccination program
some people choose not to take the
vaccination children are not vaccinated
the young are yet to be
vaccinated so there's still a big chunk
of people out there
who haven't been vaccinated the question
is how
big is that surge and how does it impact
on the nhs because
the whole road map now is designed to
unlock society
and not put the nhs at a crisis point as
we have seen it so
stretched over the winter in recent
weeks
yeah and on the issue of travel uh and
you know summer holidays and and travel
to see
families people haven't seen for for
months and months
there is this travel task force
considering things but government
scientists increasingly seem to be
saying
you know summer holidays in the uk don't
think about
going abroad and i think lord bethel was
it who's saying a number of european
countries could be on the red list
before too long
well the thing is mark is that you that
you can't get the answer yet because
uh ministers scientists they simply
don't know we know that we are
uh being vaccinated at a rapid pace but
we're also seeing a third wave across
europe
countries such as germany now enforcing
lockdowns countries such as france
seeing really big
numbers of cases and of course that will
feed into the government's decision
making
they are looking at this we're going to
hear about that
in may but at the moment i think there
is a big
line from ministers when you're asking
them about this which is
be cautious don't take any decisions
and don't book a summer holiday at the
moment because it's not nailed on
that you'll be able to go that will meet
no doubt with
opposition from travel companies and
airlines who are saying well we
we've made we've been making bookings
for the last few weeks
yes but then you have to look at it from
the other point of view which is when
you look at back at last summer and what
happened
uh the big spike in between the summer
was imported
yeah i'm going to jump in boris johnson
is about to speak when i asked you to go
lock down exactly a year ago it seemed
incredible that in the 21st century this
was the only way to fight a new
respiratory disease to stay at home
to avoid human contact to shun so many
of the patterns of behavior
that are most natural and obvious to all
of us
but we did it together to protect the
nhs
to save lives and for the entire british
people
it's been an epic of endurance and
privation
of children's birthday parties cancelled
of weddings
postponed a family gatherings of all
kinds simply deleted
from the diary and worst of all
in that time we've suffered so many
losses
and for so many people our grief has
been made
more acute because we've not been able
to see our loved ones in their final
days
to hold their hands or even to mourn
them
together and at the right moment
we will come together as a country to
build a fitting and a permanent memorial
to the loved ones we've lost and to
commemorate this whole period
for month after month our collective
fight against coronavirus was like
fighting in the dark against a callous
and invisible enemy until science
helped us to turn the lights on and to
gain the upper hand and i
want to renew my thanks to everyone
responsible for the astounding vaccine
rollout which has enabled us to protect
more than 28
million people across the whole of the
united kingdom with a first jab
and administer more than 30 million
doses in total and i want to thank
everybody for their courage your courage
discipline and patience when people come
to describe this epidemic to future
generations
we'll tell the story of the heroes of
the nhs
and social care the pharmacists teachers
arms service personnel
shop workers transport workers the
police
and so many others but in the end
this was unlike any other struggle
in my lifetime in that our entire
population
has been engaged and it's thanks to all
of you
therefore that we can continue on our
roadmap to freedom
we will meet our targets offering a
first dose to everyone over 50 by the
middle of next month
as well as those under 50 who are
clinically vulnerable
and offering a first dose of vaccine to
every adult
by the end of july and
cautiously but irreversibly step by step
jab
by jab this country is on the path
to reclaiming our freedoms thank you
very much and i'm now going to
go to chris who's going to do the slides
thank you prime minister first slide
please
um the first slide uh is uh i've just
shown
from september of last year because the
data from this time last year as
everyone will remember
we just didn't have the testing capacity
to be comparable to what
we have today and
as you can see the rates of numbers of
people testing positive for covid
in the uk is continuing to fall
but this is flattening off to some
extent over the last
week and this is expected at this point
of the curve in terms of it's going down
but going down more slowly
and we have always expected there to be
some upward pressure
as people went back to school and some
unlocking happened and this is
expected as part of the process next
slide please
fortunately the number of people in
hospital with covid
and this shows data right back to april
of
last year has come right down
and is continuing to fall rapidly
through a combination
of everyone's efforts on the lockdown
which is driving the significant
reduction
in cases and the vaccine rollout which
is particularly accelerating this
in people who are in the older age
groups
and those are pre-existing health
conditions next slide please
and if we look at the number of deaths
registered
weekly in the uk and these are the
official deaths
registered again going back to this time
last year you can see the very rapid
spike up that we had this time from this
time last year
then really right down to normal normal
rates
very close to normal rates over the
summer but then the first part
of the second wave and then when we got
the new variant
the second part of the second wave which
is now fortunately again
due to a combination of everyone's work
on lockdown
which is bringing the rates right down
and vaccines which protecting the most
vulnerable
these are falling and falling rapidly
and as you can see they're falling much
more rapidly
now than the rates of rate of decline of
the number of cases
next slide please i think as we are at
this point this sort of anniversary when
lockdown started
i just wanted to show one additional
slide to put this in context
uh some people sometimes say well
did this make a how much of a big
difference does this make to overall
mortality what you have
is the dotted line here shows the
average number of deaths the five year
average
and you can see very clearly the very
substantial
spike we had in mortality at the first
wave
a rather lower one uh in the first bit
of the second wave and then when the
new variant started a second very
substantial spike
on top of the background rate of people
dying
naturally and if and the ons data that
came out today
this morning said that there had been
overall
since the beginning of the epidemic in
the uk
147
179 people this is
uh to their most their most recent data
to the end of the 12th of march
uh who have sadly died from covid uh
more will do so but we are now on the
downward slope
and then when they looked at the excess
deaths the number of people who died
in addition to the number of people who
would have died normally
uh it was a hundred and eleven thousand
six hundred and forty one and i think
everybody uh
watching and listening to this will
mourn every single one of those deaths
next slide please but the rates
of mortality are fortunately now falling
uh rapidly
and that is due to a combination of the
lockdown as i said and this is the other
thing which the prime minister talked
about
the steady increase now in the number of
people who are vaccinated
and we now have a have a situation where
the great majority of people over 65
have now had their first vaccine and
some people in the oldest groups
are now receiving their second vaccine
or people who are frontline healthcare
workers
so the vaccine program continues to be
very important for making sure that as
new surges happen which they are likely
to at some point
they will meet a wall of vaccinated
people which will help to
significantly reduce the ratio of people
who catch
the disease to the number of people who
die from it
thank you very much thanks very much
chris patrick anything to add thank you
very much let's go to sheila from
edinburgh
how is the government planning to stop
the spread of the third wave
from continental europe into the uk
are there plans for lateral flow tests
for laundry drivers entering the country
and hotel quarantine for everyone else
coming to the uk
from anywhere abroad well uh
sheila thank you very much yes indeed we
must be very wary of the the potential
for a third wave
as as chris has just said uh sadly uh
uh we're seeing on the on the european
continent we are seeing
uh distinct uh signs of a of a third
wave
and uh they're taking steps to uh
to uh to abate that to deal with that
and
um we in the in the uk have very tough
measures at our borders already
including uh mandatory tests for anybody
who
who comes here you have to get a do a
passenger locator form you get
fined uh two thousand pounds if you fail
to fill one in
and then when you uh when you get home
from wherever you have come from
uh you have to get a test on
day two as well as day eight and again
you can be very heavily fined if you
if you fail to comply and you fail to
quarantine at home
as for people coming from the uh the 35
red list uh countries there are indeed
uh uh sheila there are indeed uh
uh measures to take them directly from
uh that point of arrival in the uk
to hotel quarantine where they stay for
10 days
as well and again have to have to do
two tests but as for your points about
about lorry drivers and hotel quarantine
for absolutely
everybody we keep i want to be i want to
be clear with the
the public we keep all these measures
under review uh insofar as it's
necessary
to take extra measures to protect uh
this country against
uh new variants variants of concern of
course uh we're
to do that um and i think we'll go
on to tim from northampton and tim from
northampton asks it's been reported that
studies have found
vaccine antibodies to last only a few
months does that mean that vulnerable
groups vaccinated first
will need to be prioritized for a second
vaccination cycle
before young people have even had their
their first that is an extremely good
question but i think it's probably a
question for
uh clinicians rather than uh and
scientists rather than
for me so i'm going to go to to to chris
first of all
who would like to go closer patrick um
i think if you look at the um the
antibody response to natural infection
which is probably the best data we've
got in terms of
long-term effects you see them really
lasting pretty well out to six months we
don't know
a long time beyond that and i think the
expectation is that um
antibodies to vaccines will also last
for a reasonable
period we don't know exactly how long
because obviously people haven't been
vaccinated for a very long period so you
may see some slight decline
but on the whole the va the antibody
levels are holding up
the second thing to say is that the
response to a vaccine
is only part the antibody response there
are other parts of the immune system
t cells and memory cells and other
things are an important part of the
overall response
and so i don't think there's any
indication yet that vaccine effects are
waving
that said there will be a need to
think about boosted jabs for vaccines in
the autumn i suspect particularly
thinking about getting high level of
immunity to cover things
over the winter i think
the additional thing just to add is that
the the second reason for
having to do a second vaccine is if we
got a variant that
uh had a relative escape from uh current
vaccines
and that would be another reason why we
might need to do revaccination
thanks very much uh both and thanks tim
laura koonsburg bbc
thank you prime minister the country's
been through so much in the last 12
months and so many people today are
grappling with everything that's
happened um professor whittie sir
patrick
and you prime minister can i ask if
there's one thing you wish you'd done
differently in the last year what would
it be
well uh i i kind of had a feeling you
were going to ask something like that
laura and you're absolutely right and i
think in retrospect there
are there are probably many things that
uh we wish
that we'd known and many things that we
wished that
we'd done differently at the time in in
retrospect
because we were fighting a novel uh
disease under
very uh different circumstances i think
than any
uh previous government had imagined i i
think that the point i've made
to you before the perhaps the single
biggest thing
uh that we uh the single biggest false
assumption
uh that we made it was about the
potential for asymptomatic
transmission and and that did govern a
lot of policy
uh in the early days or that
misunderstanding about the reality
of asymptomatic transmission certainly
uh led to
uh real problems that uh uh
we we then uh really had to work very
very hard to
to to make up ground but uh you know
we've been learning the the whole time
and we're continuing to learn
i mean i just wish we knew then what we
know now i mean we've learned an
enormous amount about this virus about
how it transmits about
um asymptomatic transmission about how
it spreads in different environments
about how to treat it there's a whole
host of things that that would have been
nice to know then the one thing that i
think
would have been really important earlier
on is to have much better data on what
was happening
and that would have required testing to
be up and ready immediately and it would
have required
the ability to get that information into
a source
and to be able to see it we can monitor
the epidemic really really well now and
understand when changes are taking place
we simply didn't have that at the
beginning and and it was very difficult
to know the speed at which things were
moving
and therefore make decisions based on
the um
real-time data uh which we can do now
and that would have made a big
difference i think
i think the thing i'd add to that i mean
i completely agree obviously with both
of those
ones uh is that um our understanding not
only of
uh the speed of things in the uk uh was
based on the fact we didn't have really
sufficient data and it wasn't until
people started
getting into hospital and dying we had
we had a really better fix on how
fast things were moving so that was very
important
but at an earlier stage we had
a much less of an understanding about
how widespread
the virus was in europe for exactly the
same reason actually because of the lack
of testing in europe as well as in the
uk
and so the uh we in retrospect we now
know
the amounts of importation there were
from spain from france and from bits of
italy that didn't obviously have a
problem
for example but at the time we didn't
have that information and that would
almost certainly have led to
uh slightly different approaches to how
we how we did things
thanks laura dan here at itv you prime
minister and you talked then about
learning lessons reflecting today
do you wish you would lock down the
country much sooner both in the spring
last year
and then again in the autumn and a
second if i may and
yesterday itv news uncovered the most
shocking and appalling housing
conditions in croydon which experts have
said
are the worst they have ever seen it
poses serious questions for the landlord
croydon council
but we know just under half a million
people in england are living in
substandard social housing
what have you done as prime minister to
help people living in poor social
housing conditions
well dan first of all on on your
question about
uh the timing of the decisions that we
uh that we took
these are very very hard decisions and
and there are no
good outcomes either way as as
as i think uh all our viewers understand
all these consequences are are very very
tough uh for people and uh
all i can say is we took all the
decisions uh with the
uh the interests of the of the british
people foremost in our hearts and
uh in in an effort to protect uh the
public and
to prevent death and suffering that was
what we were trying to do at all stages
uh though doubtless
there will be a moment to properly uh to
review uh to learn lessons
and to make sure that we you know we
learn those lessons down
uh for future uh pandemics of a kind
that i'm sure that there will be and
uh on on croydon uh which
uh i believe is currently uh controlled
by uh
the labour party uh we are uh
that i remember when i was mayor of that
uh of croydon and everywhere else in
london uh
building huge quantities of uh of social
housing and encouraging
uh development of uh uh of all kinds
in croydon and uh i i greatly regret the
uh the story and the facts that you've
uncovered uh just now
what we've got to do as a as a country
is
uh work together uh to build that better
from the pandemic
and particularly to give people the
opportunity not just
uh to rent uh their homes uh written
their social home and what the perhaps
the single biggest thing
we've done is increase the local uh
housing allowance
uh to uh write the way up
uh the uh the the house the local
rental average uh so we put much more
money into the pockets of those who need
to rent
uh locally uh to support those on the
on the lowest income that's probably one
of the most important things we've done
to support
uh social housing but in the end uh
you've got to build
more uh homes and that is the ambition
of this
of this government we want to build 300
000 homes
a year and and if you look at our
planning reforms everything that we're
doing
to drive that forward that's what we can
do croydon as it happens
uh offers fantastic opportunities uh for
for more development as as i'm sure you
know as i as i well
remember and uh it would be a great
thing if the
uh if the current uh mayor of london uh
without
putting too fine a point on it uh dan uh
addressed the issue uh himself and
that's what uh uh i would like to see
uh let's go to beth rigby of sky news
thank you prime minister finally after a
very long
and hard year the end is now in sight
but no one can doubt the huge scar kovid
is going to leave on our economy on
public health and on the lives of all
our children
and to each of you what do you think the
main
social health and economic challenges
will be
and will we be grappling with the legacy
of
covid in the past year for the rest of
our lives
thank you beth i
certainly think that this is something
that we will all remember and
be dealing with in different ways for
probably for certainly in my case for as
long as uh
as i live it's been an extraordinary uh
moment in our in our in our history in a
deeply
difficult and and distressing period if
i look at the
uh the problems that uh we face at the
moment in addition to the
the the the continuing health care uh
threat that we face
you know we must be realistic there is
uh another wave uh building in uh in in
on the european continent uh amongst our
friends uh we will see it wash onto our
shores i i i have no doubt
the the extent to which it affects us
will depend as
as chris was saying on the strength of
the fortifications
we've now built against it by the by the
vaccine program
uh that's that's that's one problem
we've still got to deal with but
the legacy issue i think for me uh
leaving aside all the all the other
backlogs
is is education and it's the loss
of of learning for so many uh children
and young people that's the thing we've
got to focus on now as a
as a society and that and that i think
is an opportunity to make amends
uh because you know there's going to be
uh this year a group of kids going from
primary to secondary school
there'll be uh perhaps 90 000 it's
calculated
uh who will uh be behind in their basic
literacy
uh unable properly to read all right
nine thousand more as a result
of of covid uh a huge between three and
five months
of education has been lost uh and of
course the
the detriment uh falls the hardest on
the uh the kids who have needed
attention the most and and who have
uh been unable to who haven't been
provided properly with uh the time and
the
uh and the support that they need so
that's why we've been working so hard as
a government to make up that gap uh with
everything that we
uh we've done uh through the uh through
the holiday support
through uh investment in in the catch-up
funds uh the 1.7 billion
uh that we've put in uh everything we've
done to roll out laptops
across the as many kids as as we could
uh and that's why uh in addition to the
work that gavin
williamson is doing we as a sir kevin
collins
uh is the uh education recovery uh
commissioner
who is leading that work of recovery and
what sir kevin and his team are going to
be focusing on is not just
uh remediating the damage repairing uh
the damage plugging the gaps
uh but i think there's there's a chance
to to learn from the
the pandemic and the and all the ways in
which actually some
teachers and some schools have done
brilliantly at uh discovering how you
can teach
uh through zoom discovering ways in
which we can actually
uh teach better in some ways through the
technology that we've been using
but also maximizing our use of
of tutoring as well so that uh kids who
have fallen behind
and kids with potential get one to one
tutoring uh where we think that can make
a difference and you know i'm not going
to pretend that everything is going to
work
first time and you know we've been
through a long period where we know
we've got used to things not working
uh first time but we're going to
persevere and i think that
we will we will start to make a big
impact on on those kids lives
it's been an absolutely
unimaginable year for uh for school
children for
university students for everybody in in
education
they've put up with incredible
privations
uh in order to to help us the whole
country get through
and our whole our future as a country
depends on
us now repaying that generation
making sure they get the education they
need so that's
that's the stuff for me that's the the
biggest priority
i mean just narrowly on the health side
um
covet itself i anticipate being with us
for the foreseeable future we'll have to
deal with it in some form or another now
science has
extraordinarily responded to this if you
think where we were a year ago
vaccines drugs diagnostics and
understanding of the virus we will be
able to bring it down to manageable
levels but it's not going away so we
will have covid
for the indefinite future second thing
uh which is a health issue from covered
and we've said this right from the
beginning this is one of the things
we've been very concerned about right
from the beginning
collectively is that the impact on other
aspects of the health service will
have some delayed effect there will be
people
for example who probably delayed having
screening and i would really encourage
people
to take that up for things like cervical
cancer breast cancer
which have run the risk of people having
a delayed diagnosis the same will be
true for people who have not gone for
routine or elective care
they normally was that's a medium term
issue but potentially could be a
significant one if we are not
uh absolutely alive to it and the third
one which again we recognized fully from
the beginning and one of the things
that's made so many of the decisions
very difficult
is much of what's happened in lockdown
has the risk of making people who are on
the board lines of deprivation
uh in more difficult economic and other
circumstances and we all know that has a
massive
impact on long-term health implications
so
that and that could have really quite a
long-term implications again if we don't
take it seriously i suppose the final
point i'd make is that
kovid has shown a light into areas of
healthcare the people who are being
affected by covid now
are the same families the same places
the same people who are affected by so
many other diseases and i think we
really need to look at this very
seriously
because these you know the the same
people will be
suffering from the diseases of smoking
of other diseases of deprivation and so
on
we've really got i think to take this
very seriously as a as
a country and as a community i think uh
i mean clearly today is a day to think
about
all the people who've died this year as
a result of this terrible virus but also
the people who've suffered both physical
and mental health
and all of the consequences that come
with that and the societal effects
and um in september i asked the british
academy
to get their academics together to try
and
address the question what might the
societal impact long-term societal
impacts of kovid b
and they've got 200 of the brightest and
best of
of of the fellows of the british academy
and a report was published today
trying to give an evidence base for what
that might look like and
there are a number of things in there
ranging from the topics that have been
covered from education to inequality to
health
that i think are highlighted and have
profound implications for how
policy might evolve but what's important
is that there's an evidence base now to
work on
and that report i think will be useful
for policy makers going forward
thank you uh thanks both and thanks beth
ben riley smith telegraph
thank you a question for the prime
minister and also the government
scientists
she actually picks up on chris whitney's
comments there we're a year into this
pandemic
should the uk government's policy
objective now be to eradicate covid
or simply bring down cases to the lowest
possible levels
well ben i think it's the second uh in
in the sense that i i'm not sure
listening to the scientists intently as
i have
uh for many many months i'm not sure
that that that eradication
uh makes sense in a in a globalized
economy for for one country alone
plainly as a
an objective for humanity it's it's it's
it's right and and we should we should
aim for it but
uh that's that's that's my uh that's my
that's my view but um but i'd hand up
chris and patrick
i i regret i regret to say
that i think the chances of eradicating
this disease which means getting rid of
it absolutely everywhere
are as close to zero as makes no
difference we've only achieved
eradication of one disease which is
smallpox
with a phenomenally effective vaccine
over a very
a very long period of time literally
hundreds of years
so um and others have come close but
it's very difficult in terms of
eliminating from the uk
this is a disease which uh is got most
people
who have it have mild symptoms or in
some cases no symptoms who can then
transmit it that makes it very difficult
to find
we have good vaccines very good vaccines
they're not 100 effective vaccines
we have good tests but not everybody who
needs testing
is tested and really would strongly
encourage people to
do that i think everyone agrees we can
get covered rates right down that should
be absolutely our aim
and to get cases of people who die and
have severe disease
as close to zero as we can
if we can go further every who would say
no
but i think if you talk to anybody who
looks at this really seriously who
understands how infectious diseases work
i don't think there's anybody who thinks
eliminating from the uk or eradicating
globally
for any long period of time is a
realistic
prospect at this point in time i i agree
i think
get numbers as low as we can don't
expect that this is going
to disappear expect that there will be
recurrences of infections particularly
in winter
and this will become a circulating virus
as
as others have done over over thousands
of years and i think this is this is
unfortunately
what what we have i think the chances of
eradication true eradication ie
zero are in themselves very close to
zero as chris has said
thanks ben uh dominick yeitman metro
hi thank you prime minister when the
time comes as you put it to describe
this period
to future generations how will we
explain why britain suffered the highest
death toll in europe in the deepest
recession
and secondly if i may people who own
holiday homes
overseas such as your father for
instance
uh will be exempted from the travel ban
affecting everyone else
would you advise people to buy a second
home abroad if they want to have a
holiday this year
and a quick one for the scientists if i
may
uh are the new variants enough to
explain
why the second wave killed more people
than the first
uh dominic on your on your your overall
question about
uh you know your sort of uh league table
question i you know i think i will uh
respectfully
uh go back to the answer that you'll
have heard from this uh podium
many times which is that uh the uh
the the pandemic is uh uh alas
tragically is not over yet uh across the
world
uh we mourn the loss of every life
that's been lost
in this country we're going to continue
to uh protect
uh everyone as to the best of the best
of our ability but you know this is this
uh is is not over and i think that
international comparisons
uh are uh are premature at this stage
and on uh on your second point
really about uh global uh
uh travel uh and uh and holidays
a lot of people do want to know about
[Music]
what's going to happen on on the on the
holiday front and
um i i know there's a great deal of
curiosity and interest all i can say is
it is just too early
uh to say and so my advice is to
everybody to wait
uh for the global travel task force to
report we've heard already that
there are uh other european countries
where the disease is now
rising so things certainly look
difficult uh for for the time being
uh but uh we'll be we'll be able to say
more
uh we hope in a in a few days time i
suddenly hope to be
uh saying some more by uh by april the
fifth and
and uh that's i think the best uh best
you can hope for there
in terms of the question you asked uh uh
us uh
uh patrick may want to add to this but
um
you know it's very difficult to be
absolutely confident exactly what
happened we're very confident that the
majority of people who died
in the second half of the second wave
which is by far the bigger one
were from the new variant so first thing
is that
has done that just completely has taken
over really in the uk
and that is now the variant so that is
that is what has driven
a lot of these now working out what
would have happened had the new variant
not arrived
is really difficult to do and i think
anyone who claims that they
they they can with confidence is is
misunderstanding the problem
but uh the the height of the peak
would undoubtedly be a lot lower had
that
new much more transmissible and probably
more more fatal but that is more
questionable but the transmissibility i
don't think is questionable
uh had that not arrived i think the
pattern of the second wave in the uk
would have been very different and what
you can see when you see what's
happening in continental europe at the
moment
is the effects of the arrival of the
b117 variant
is actually causing problems in other
countries as it has caused problems
uh now i share the pm's uh caution about
trying to do international comparisons
although i will make a technical point
that if you're going to do it it's
probably best to concentrate on
on or excess or cause mortality just
because that's easier to
compare between countries but that's a
minor technical point the general point
is we had a bad outcome
many other countries had a bad outcome
what we want to try and do is to
minimise mortality in the future and
learn lessons from the past
nothing thank you very much uh chris and
dominic
emilio casalicchio from politico
thanks uh promised um i've got a couple
of related questions for you
and one for the scientists if that's
okay um the eu
wants us to share our order of vaccines
from a plant in the netherlands
uh called the halex factory and it's
been making threats to impose a ban on
the jabs coming to britain if we refuse
to share
um can you answer yes or no whether
we're going to share them which
presumably would help
prevent that third wave in the eu from
reaching our shores
and the bigger question is can we afford
to share them meaning
if we give however many million doses to
the eu will we still have enough to keep
our rollout on course
and the question for the scientists are
that there are fears that
if the eu does place an export ban on
some vaccines to the uk
we might retaliate and get into a kind
of trade war
um some of those fears are coming from
pfizer which is warned that if we stop
sending vaccine components made in
britain to the eu
their production could grind to a halt
and presumably that could harm
our overall vaccine supplies as well so
do you worry that a tit for
trade war with the eu could put the the
uk rollout at any risk at
all well thanks very much emilia let me
go first and say
uh that we're all fighting
the same pandemic across the whole of
the european
continents and indeed around much of the
much of the world and
vaccines are an international
operation they're produced by
collaboration between great
international
uh scientists it's a fantastic thing to
see how they've uh
been uh developed uh and we'll continue
to work with
uh european partners to uh
to to deliver uh the vaccine rollout uh
what i can say is
uh that we in this country uh don't
believe in uh
in blockades uh of any kind of
of vaccines or vaccine material
uh not something that this country would
dream of
of engaging in and i'm encouraged by
some of the things i've heard
uh from the continent uh in the same
sense
it's a miracle we've got vaccines it's
been an incredible
um effort by scientists from around the
world we've got
companies academic groups others who've
discovered produce vaccines right the
way around the world
and in a sense the clue to this is in
the title of the problem we've got which
is a pandemic it affects everywhere
this is something that's only going to
be sorted out when everybody is sorted
out and therefore it needs
an approach which takes an international
approach to how we
solve this problem of the of of the
virus
so i'll just i'll just add to that and
we're all basically saying the same
thing which is
uh every single one of the vaccines we
have available
depends on science from multiple
countries for its intellectual origins
for its immediate recent development and
in almost all cases for its
manufacturing distribution is absolutely
essential we see this as an
international problem
and scientists collaborate the whole
time so patrick and i
talked to our counterparts in europe the
whole time scientists up and down
the uk all four nations of the uk are
talking to their counterparts in europe
and in every other nation
uh as as appropriate the whole time this
should be seen as an
international issue there's no point in
one country
being immunized on its own we need the
the whole planet to be inoculated thank
you all very much thank you
so there we are boris johnson talking
about this nation's many losses
in the last year and the grief which he
said
has been made more acute because in many
cases people have not been able to be
with loved ones before they died
he talked about building a fitting and
permanent memorial
to those who had died he said at the
beginning it was like fighting in the
dark against a callous and invisible
enemy until
scientists turned on the light and the
vaccines came
it has been unlike any other struggle in
my lifetime he said because it involved
the whole population
but now he said we are on a path to
regaining
our freedom he was asked about what he
wished they'd done differently
he said many things we wish we'd known
and many things we wished we'd
uh done differently are specifically
about lockdown and whether he wished he
had locked down
on two occasions earlier he said these
are very hard decisions
and there are no good outcomes either
way
asked by beth rigby about the future
and covid boris johnson said the effects
will be with us
uh certainly for the rest of my life i
think he said
and chris whittie said covert is with us
for the foreseeable future the chance of
eliminating it
uh getting rid of it at all next to zero
so let's go to
beth rigby who asked a question
that broadly speaking beth as you
predicted
it was largely reflective in tone
it was mark and as i thought there was
no
news line there was no announcement of a
covid
inquiry it was rather to reflect on the
past
year and also the prime minister there
as he did at cabinet
this morning wanting to thank care
workers
nhs staff bus drivers train
drivers shop staff postmen delivery
drivers the people that have basically
kept the nation
uh chartering along uh during this
pandemic and that is what he did as well
as thanking the scientists but
if you were going to are expecting
sort of explicit words of regret it
wasn't the moment that the prime
minister wanted to reflect
on what has gone wrong on whether he did
lock down too late there's been lots of
focus around september when
sage recommended that the prime minister
introduce that circuit breaker you'll
remember it in the october
half ten term and he didn't lock down
until
five weeks later that will in an inquiry
no doubt be
an area that is poured over and and
considered deeply but
as for regrets or what did we want to do
differently
all of those gentlemen acknowledging
that there were things they didn't know
that there were things that they
would do differently but today was not
the day to go into the specifics as far
as they were
concerned i was interestingly at the end
chris whitty
when he was asked about the excess death
rate the ons figure saying 150
000 excess deaths in the uk
uh from covert he said we had a bad
outcome
he then said other countries had a bad
outcome too but if you measure it per
capita
around the world we really are in the
bottom league there we really did have
a very very bad covert in terms of
mortality rates
um but in terms of looking forward in
the future
the prime minister there really honing
in on education
and trying to pick up some learning for
those children that have
lost education over the past year the
thing that struck me was when he said as
you
said mark was he said i will be living
with the consequence
of cloverd for as long as i live which
is
as you would expect really that what
happened in the past year
will have an effect into the future
beyond this decade perhaps into the next
decade when you think of the
huge amount of economic expenditure
expenditure
over 400 billion pounds of funding put
into the kovic crisis
children losing over half a year of
school
the mental health the physical health
fallout chris whittie they're talking
about people
not getting screening the backlog of
cases
for the nhs so really
as we reflect on the past year at the
kind of
the the mountain we have to climb in
terms of repair in society the economy
and our health after it i think was was
laid bare there too
on practical issues as well as for
summer holidays
the prime minister there asked
explicitly about it
he simply said it is too early to say
he said that he would give an update for
us on
april the 5th so maybe there'll be
another press conference or a statement
that day which we should look out for
and he said things certainly look
difficult for the time
being so no certainty on whether we're
going to get our holidays this year
abroad
yeah and just finally a quick word beth
on what patrick valance said which was
quite interesting
when asked what he would have done
differently or wish they could have done
differently when he said
he wished that they'd had much better
data earlier on but then added
but for that we would have needed a much
better test and trace system
early on yes and if you
think back to the first lockdown the
first wave
lots of the problems that scientists
were having was that we just did not
have
uh an efficient track and trace system
again this is all about the lessons
learned and we will need to learn those
lessons because
as the government wrote in itself in its
integrated review you'll remember that
big document about
diplomacy security foreign policy for
the next
decade it explicitly talks about
pandemic pandemic preparedness
and the need to actually make sure that
what went wrong in the past year
we put right so that next time this
happens we will be
better resourced and better prepared but
as i said
uh the government has promised an
official
inquiry as to when it comes the prime
minister kicking that into the long
grass for now
okay beth thank you very much indeed
this